our friends used to say I was like
Charles Manson because like I would get
everyone high but then I wouldn't get
high myself just fire trust a
professional 1 2 3
everyone's about making products that
are accessible for everyone you know the
type of product that the type of
restaurant you'd like to go to which
serve to its customers that is what our
mission is there's a different type of
product and it's gonna make people
happier and make the world better
but it's not gonna put us to Mars but
maybe if I like I'll make the trip
better
people often compare this industry to
the Internet boom that sort of tech boom
of the late 90s you know of the eight
billion people on our planet how many of
them use psychoactives regularly almost
all of them either do currently or will
in the future and when you think about
it the market opportunity for something
like this is it meant
welcome to canopyboulder
2015 we made it and we're here to make
businesses that do ancillary products
and services around cannabis we do not
consume cannabis in canopyboulder though
the first month think of it as learning
learn about investors learn about
fundraising finance legal marketing
advertising HR I'm Carter Baird Carter
Baird aka the pot scientist I wouldn't I
don't want to say we are like Etsy for
the cannabis industry but we have
certain features that Etsy has a web web
magazine focusing on cannabis lifehacks
I'm a YouTube vlogger about weed science
and marijuana culture we are going to us
becoming the Amazon for the industry ken
hacker is life is like life hacker it's
a more niche version my youtube channels
called TPS reports I'm TPS and I reports
we want to be the bridge that pulls this
of event data in and gets it in the
Salesforce the word compliance is cool
it suggests that you're in compliance
with law in this industry I would put
management team at the top of the list
when we look at people and companies in
this industry over the last five years
we've seen the caliber increase they're
still not quite as good as what I was
used to in Silicon Valley but they're
getting better this is our state medical
marijuana license this is our state
retail or adult use marijuana license
our Clearcreek medical marijuana infused
products license dark retail marijuana
infused products license this is a
certification that our building has been
certified at EBI we make feelings we
have five feelings chill bliss giggle
energy and create so we'll go in
to show you guys the lab excited so this
side of the building is where we do a
lot of the extraction and the
purification let's take a look at what
Kurt's doing over here eventually what
we will do is use the supercritical
fluid chromatography to isolate each
individual cannabinoid and terpene or
whatever we wants so is this how you're
able to produce different effects if
you're isolating different cannabinoids
then you can produce the chill effect or
you can produce the something else
effect is that really kind of exactly
how you're doing what you're doing here
yeah it's Duma calling from Abu how're
you doing between the patients in the
hospital it sounds like a busy day for
you there's an interest for you to get
on board we'd love to do it before the
first of September that 250 is our
minimum yeah I mean you know obviously
we have the ability to make exceptions
thank you
Thanks bye he's he's a past I'm pretty
clear to me that like you know that I
would prefer to go with something like
this this this or this if I'm a consumer
and I buy this yeah but that sucks like
is it's gonna look like that doesn't
look good
but the gloopy stuff is better it's a
fucking great man I don't see why we
just don't see this
in 1975 in Colorado there were three
pages of laws on the books regarding
cannabis now we have over a thousand
pages what ended up happening is big
money from California New York and and
Florida moved into our state and bought
language that basically demonized and
keeps it illegal for the rest of us the
tree of life back in 2009 used to be
able to walk into one Brad Mouse and on
the chalkboard we would have 80 to 100
grade a organic strains of cannabis at
30 types of hashish non-solvent
and then over here there'd be a
beautiful glass case full of cannabis in
mason jars and people would literally be
able to pick what Bud they wanted and
see me weigh it in front of them and it
really filled the aroma in the in the
dispensary was beautiful culture we're
giving is more important than taking and
receiving and that is being lost in the
corporatization of the cannabis plant
well a lot of companies even with good
ideas in this industry are having a hard
time raising capital I think in five
years you'll see the emergence of
national and international brands that
that are well-known you go to a
conference when you meet 100 investors
and they will tell other investors oh
yeah that guy was really weird right
this is your chance to be called weird
in a safe place I'm looking to invest in
the cannabis industry oh really
yeah what brought you to the cannabis
industry ah great agreed that the money
category your job is the excellent
person being interviewed is to arrest
that control and have it still feel
natural I don't want to be mean that I
would he does first this is like going
to the bar and trying to pick up a check
there is no guaranteed way to do it I
wake up every morning worried that
cannabis legalization is right around
the corner and why is that dangerous
because you're come as soon as if I said
interests your company because if we're
not ready when that happens we'll get
put out of business by a big you know
multinational conglomerate in the
alcohol or tobacco industry go they'll
crush us I should make sure I have a
good podcast that's very important they
listen to this American life I listen to
that money
when I get up here it's time to think
and you come up here you watch the
clouds move across the mountaintops you
know I'm so excited about you know
creating a better world for people than
the one I grew up in you know I grew up
in a world where your only choice for
legal psychoactive is alcohol do you do
that again that stretch yeah
one two three go it's got a nice like
woody kind of a wood enos to it I think
like Tamia reminds me of like a you know
an aged liqueur that has you know which
is perfect as it's Almanac right who
actually nailed it great it's actually
the strain and what it's supposed to do
and so when investors ask no what's my
ten acts what do you tell him you're 10x
returned yeah my top it's gonna be a
hundred or a thousand or a million X I
think if it's a 10x we should get fired
they should hire someone else because
like in this industry you'd have to be a
moron I go to promises if doing moron
not to be able to make money in the
cannabis industry and we're not morons
you